one day I was talking to my wife when we
were dating about flowers and she made
some offhanded comment like Ugh flowers
but turns out 10 years later when I
never bought flowers
that I had misinterpreted what she said
at all and then one day she was like how
come you never ever bought me flowers
and I was like Oh I thought you didn't
want them and she's like no
I would love to get flowers
and it was this and again this is
something very small but
she taught me
very explicitly here's what I need
here's what I would like
and man I love doing things that make my
wife happy and bring her Joy so take a
risk
be explicit about how you feel how you
feel
and then be explicit about here's what I
want and here's what I need
and give him an opportunity to step up